with more fox news contributor laura
trump outnumbered co-host kaylee
mcinerney good to see you both laura uh
i'll start with you
you know the interesting thing is
there was a debate and i played it too
many times i won't play it again where
your father-in-law said wait a minute
you're going to get rid of oil whoa
that's really big what he just said did
everyone hear him say that
he predicted on another occasion you're
going to be paying five six seven eight
dollars a gallon for gasoline joe
doubled down and said i'll eliminate
fossil fuels he said it not once we have
on record saying it four times
so he's actually following through on
what he said he would do and i don't
think most people recognize that part
well they ought to and it's unfortunate
that this is something that actually joe
biden has followed through on um and
it's hurting americans across the board
but you're right think back to those
rallies the times that you heard my
father-in-law president donald trump
talk about what would happen if joe
biden ever became president of the
united states and when he said that when
he said that about the gas prices sean
talking about six seven eight nine
dollar gasoline uh per gallon people
said that will never happen it is
happening right now across our country
and this is only 18 months into the
biden presidency what else did president
donald trump predict he predicted a
recession on the rise if joe biden
became president of the united states i
think most people in this country look
at what's happening with our economy
they look at the high gas prices they
look at the inflation they look at the
fact that people don't have the
discretionary money they used to have to
go on vacations to go to a movie to go
to a restaurant that hurts the economy
across the board and it's a bit of a
waterfall effect what does that lead to
likely a recession every expert has
agreed on that and you know you also
played some of those clips just a moment
ago
of the hysteria from the media over my
father-in-law walking down a ramp but
don't forget it wasn't just that it was
the time and time again getting the
white house doctor out in front of the
media to ask about two scoops of ice
cream and look i i struggle to find
anything i agree with joe biden on
it's true he is though the
representation of america around the
world and to have a guy that can't even
ride a bicycle quite frankly it is sad
to see that our allies see that our
enemies see that it is just another way
america looks weaker and is weaker under
president joe biden you know kaylee i
thought about you because karine
jean-pierre the new white house press
secretary she was the one when biden
tripped not once not twice but three
times
uh going up air force one
on air force one she was asked about it
and she said it was very windy outside
so i don't know what's worse the fact
that he fell over three times or that
they're claiming the wind knocked him
over okay then she said last week you
know oh this president he's got so much
energy i could barely keep up with her
with him and i'm like she must be in
really bad shape because it looks like
anybody can keep up with him
yeah it is absolutely pathetic sean i
every time i came to the podium not
every time but many of the times i would
be asked about this secret visit
that president trump had to walter reed
and oh did he have a stroke all of these
things that were just totally out of
line totally false it was a standard
routine visit but the press would
speculate and ask over and over again
about it the ramp saga the new york
times their headline was that they were
questioning his health and then the
byline the subject line right underneath
it said and he struggled to lift a glass
of water sean this is the man who i had
a hard time following around to five
rallies in a day five rallies he would
go until after midnight
is anybody watching you think that he's
capable joe biden's capable of five
rallies in a day i don't think so
absolutely not i've done four cities in
a day on a book to one what's that laura
yeah
so maybe one from his basement and and
rally is a very loose term if you have
eight people in hula that's true you
know probably you know maybe seven or
eight people but imagine if you said um
on air force one if donald trump tripped
even one time going up the steps to air
force one um it's very windy outside
what would the reaction would
what might it be or if donald trump had
no energy like joe and you said with a
straight face i can't even keep up with
him i'm like if you can't keep up with
him you don't belong in that job
yeah that's exactly right we don't have
to guess this sean because president
trump said you know it was a slight
hydro plane that he had on the ramp
which is absolutely the case i've walked
on some of those ramps at rallies
they're very slippery and of course the
sinister press said oh well it wasn't
raining outside yeah it didn't have a
rail oh well it wasn't raining that must
be a lie no it's just a basic fact that
the ramps are slippery but they will
make every excuse in the world for joe
biden he was wearing dress shirts over
old joe if you had sneakers on you might
have a case to make uh laura you get the
last word
well here's what i'll say i actually
ride a bike quite often i do triathlons
and i'm actually clipped in to my bike
so i understand that if you're clipped
into a bike sometimes it can get a
little hairy whenever you stop he wasn't
clipped in he had tennis shoes on so
look again i just think this is a really
sad representation for america because
imagine xi jinping imagine vladimir
putin imagine kim jong-un watching the
video of joe biden falling on his bike
wow what a bad moment for america you do
triathlons i just i just do trained to
do fighting to win a fight in 30 seconds
or less and win by a big margin so i
don't know you're in way better shape
on
all right thank you both hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else